we welcome you back to cbs mornings
we're about to hear from the mother of a
murdered six-year-old his name was jesse
lewis his story led a conspiracy
theorist to admit that he told lies for
years about the sandy hook massacre last
week a jury awarded scarlett lewis
that's jesse's mom and neil hesslin
that's jesse's dad more than 49 million
dollars in damages in their lawsuit
against alex jones the couple says that
they were viciously harassed by his
followers who believed his claim that
the killings were staged
20 children we all remember this 20
little children and six adults were
killed in the 2012 mass shooting in her
testimony scarlett lewis confronted
jones directly
jesse was real i am a real mom i know
you know that that's the problem i know
you know that and you keep saying it
you keep saying it
why
we should note that alex jones later
acknowledged that the sandy hook
shooting was quote 100
real
scarlet lewis joins us first on cbs
mornings good morning to you scarlett
lewis i watched that video over and over
and i kept watching your face wondering
how you could be so calm speaking to him
because that's the first time or was it
the first time you had seen him face to
face absolutely the first time live yes
and i was literally looking into his
eyes from the witness stand and so what
were you thinking scarlett because at
one point he had accused you of being a
crisis actor
you're jesse's mom he accused you of
being a crisis actor and by implication
arguing that jessie never lived you guys
are actors and jesse was never a real
boy in the real world never existed yeah
i think this in the courtroom that day
for you as you're facing this man face
to face yeah so callous and cruel i i
was so nervous i remember taking a cup
of water and my hand was shaking
but then i looked into
alex jones's eyes who was sitting right
in front of me
and
i really felt i could only feel
compassion for him and really that's how
i maintained my composure
i had already forgiven him but that
doesn't mean that you don't hold
somebody accountable
and what i saw
was just a man
a human being
in pain
lonely
with no one there to testify for him he
had not a person there
and i find your compassion extraordinary
under the circumstances because we all
know how much you loved your little boy
you had sued for 150 million dollars in
damages you were awarded 49 million
what were your thoughts about the
verdict did you think that it was fair
were you angry about the verdict
i thought that it was fair
and really my goal was to send a message
about the importance of truth it wasn't
about the money for you not at all yeah
absolutely not no i have been
i've been spreading a choose love
movement for the past nine and a half
years with the focus of keeping kids
safe and to me everything that alex
jones was saying about the tragedy not
even being real and 24 of the american
public either doubting the facts around
sandy hook or thinking that it didn't
happen was going directly against my
goal which is to keep kids safe and
safeguard their well-being i never
thought it could be about the money for
you because nothing no amount of money
could replace your little boy you made a
decision consciously to return to this
terrible topic and confront alex jones
in court right uh that had to be a
difficult choice for you what is that
message
you're trying to send about the
importance of truth and why was it so
important to you to walk this very
difficult walk and so publicly
you know i i feel like uh
i was standing up to
my bully a bully just like my son had
stood up to his bully um which was what
did i mean by that well literally uh
jesse stood up to the shooter who came
into his first grade classroom at sandy
hook elementary school
and saved nine of his classmates lives
how did he do that uh the the uh shooter
had just killed his principal and
guidance counselor right outside his
door he turned into jesse's classroom
his gun
either jammed or ran out of bullets and
during the short delay jesse called for
his friends to run and he's literally
credited with saving nine of
their lives and so i'm sitting on the
stand and i'm thinking you know in
comparison to what jesse did
this is the easier job for sure
safeguarding truth in our country
my attorney literally asked the jury to
choose love over fear and hatred and
they did yeah you mentioned uh choose
love in that movement which is a
non-profit that you founded in jesse's
name what do you hope people take away
from that
i hope that they take away the
uh fact that our personal power as human
beings is in our ability to choose in
any moment how we thoughtfully respond
and responding with love
is the powerful choice it feel good it
feels good and it's going to lead to a
safer more peaceful and loving world and
it's all of our choices every single day
from the moment we wake up scarlett i'm
in our view honestly because i just
think i'm still haunted by as we all are
haunted by that day at sandy hook how
you're able to talk so
um
comfortably about this such boys with
such such poise and such grace
considering it had to be one of the
worst moments of your life
well how are you able to do this a
message that my six-year-old son left on
our kitchen chalkboard
is really the reason he wrote three
words nurturing healing love
and it's six years old at six years old
phonetically spelled yeah because he was
in first grade and just learning to
write yes but i knew that that was a
spiritual awareness that he had that he
wasn't going to be on earth for very
much longer
it was a message of comfort for his
family and friends but also inspiration
it's where we needed to turn in order to
survive and thrive gail was asking how
you deal and how you heal
um
we are in
terrible times i'll just call it what it
is seems like we're talking about
a mass shooting on a weekly basis over
350 since sandy hook nine and a half
years ago it might hit us differently
because it hasn't impacted us we're just
delivering the news to our viewers but
to you
when you
read another story turn on the news you
see another story about a mass shooting
how does that affect you
it's devastating it's devastating and it
makes me double down on my efforts
because i i am literally trying to
change
our direction in our country towards
truth and love and away from fear and
hate
and i believe that we're making progress
but we need everybody to join the
movement in order to be successful
extraordinary but alex jones is still
talking isn't he before he's still
talking
any remorse from him when you were
looking in his eyes and from our camera
angle we can't see his face right yeah
is there remorse there
i believe that there was i believe that
he knows that sandy hook happened
and
that he's made bad choices
and i believe that he could make
different choices going forward i think
that he wants to
um i think sometimes greed gets in the
way but um you know we have one life
and we're here really to love and
support one another and i hope that he
makes that decision i know that he knows
now that it is a choice that he can make
yes yeah all right and i have it let me
let me say this it's it's not a surprise
that jesse wrote the word nurturing on
the chalkboard at your house he didn't
get that way by himself right he didn't
get that way by himself scarlett thank
you so much thank you for coming to talk
to us this morning thank you